so yeah
this i mean this program is structured
in a way but it addresses uh
people who are uh who are who are
beginner in coding or who wants to cover
bioinformatics or who wants to cover
data science
for
for biomedical data
practically
through logic and one step if you
completely understand and the logics
behind
using these different methods on the
data then you can expand your knowledge
to either using one of the coding
platform r or using
an alternative coding platform python so
all the associated resources that i'm
going to show you today is is given in
the program page so let's quickly go
through the introduction to machine
learning in biomedical data
which is in course seven so this course
as such will give you a very brief ah
very
brief introduction and you will learn
about various different
machine learning methods of analysis
including supervised and unsupervised
machine learning methods as elia talked
about and how they apply to different
biomedical data and you can also
see examples of multi-omics integration
and and applying different data science
techniques to those integrated
multi-omics data to answer the
biological question in hand so let me go
through the first lesson
in introduction to machine learning in
biomedical data with you
so that we can get a sense of how the
lessons are organized and what to expect
from these lessons and how you are going
to maximize the
the learning potential of this platform
so here we get a very brief background
about machine learning and why we are
going to use machine learning and
why machine learning methods are
successful
in
in getting applied to different
biomedical data and why they are being
taken and why they are being considered
as the next level of analysis
for the
for the sheer volume of
biological data that is available and
then use you cause you go through the
next
session which is a purpose of this
course in this course this this tells
you what this course actually teaches
you this course will will teach you
about the methods this course will teach
you about the logic behind the methods
and this course will make you understand
how that logic is applied to different
kind of biomedical applications and in
the process you will also doing uh in
the process of doing what this course
recommends you to do you will develop
critical thinking in how to
approach biological question
in terms of data science methods and
most of these data sets are curated
datasets that are derived or that are
taken from the public uh resources from
public already published data so you
will understand what it means to
what it means to extract or what it
means to extract additional information
from a data that is primarily recorded
or primarily registered to answer a
question in mind by the authors and
going through this experience you will
also learn how to uh
as elia actually mentioned it
in in some of the examples or uh some of
the project examples and you will learn
how to specifically answer question that
is related to a particular data set in
hand and how to tailor the method all
the methods different methods and the
logic that you learned to suit to the
data that we
have that we consider in hand so
we process we preach and we actually
practice learn by doing methods so there
is no waiting time in in terms of
learning what you are going to do you do
this
you do this analysis and you learn as
you go
as you go along in this project works so
the next section actually talks about
how does machine learning work what is
the basic behind what's the logic behind
how does this machine learning work and
what's the logic behind this algor these
algorithms and and as i mentioned there
is there are two
major classification of these machine
learning algorithms one is unsupervised
and supervised i'm not going to go into
detail about what is unsupervised and
what what is supervised but on the broad
scale if you have different groups in
your data and you don't know about the
segregation of those groups then you can
use unsupervised machine learning and
you can employ different algorithm or
different set of algorithm to arrive at
a result that will segregate your data
into multitude of these groups and
similarly in a supervised machine
learning you know something about you
know something about the categorization
of your source data and then you can
learn or you can label those data based
on the based on the groupings and you
can set a training data set under test
dataset for your machine learning
algorithm to learn the pattern
pattern hidden in the data that defines
these categories and then try to apply
that to a new hidden test data and to
categorize the data into one of the
available labels so again here also we
have a multitude of different training
data sets as are multitude of different
training algorithms and that you will
employ and that you will learn the logic
behind these algorithms uh very
in a very intuitive way in in the bio uh
big data bioinformatics
platform the turbo bioinfo platform so
so when you go through this then
you go towards the applications of this
machine learning data where there is
humongous potential for this machine
learning application machine learning
methods to be applied to various uh
datasets like in clinical data pharma
biotech those are only two i mean like
in agricultural data setting the the
main future lies in uh integrating all
these different uh not only omix data
but also different
different
types of data from different sources
like the patient demographic information
like the patient history information
like
like the
history of disease in the patients uh
genealogy information all these data
will come together in a very uh
integrated way so that the machine
learning algorithm can learn and
understand the pattern behind those data
to uh to be applied
to the various applications that we say
so we also give links to uh some of the
projects where you will find uh a
specific question is answered using ah
very uh using a very detailed
methodologies
and you can go through it you can follow
those
those steps and understand how
how the approach is designed how the
method is designed to answer those
specific questions and
and there are also other uh reviews and
literature information given so all
these lessons you see here that are
logic based conclude with the conclusion
and the quiz which i uh and we all
recommend you to take so that you can um
evaluate yourself how you have processed
the information that you had uh that you
had uh been going through so uh if you
are uh if you are uh
if you are
not a
satisfied with the results you can go
through them again and then learn it and
learn it and process it much more detail
and and uh
attempt these questions and and these
quizzes are there to
expand your your own version your own
understanding of where you stand so that
completes lesson one in in the
machine learning
uh
introduction to machine learning
biomedical data so if this this lesson
and this particular course as i
mentioned uh addresses the basic the
main logic underlying the machine
learning platform now if you have
mastered that main
logic underlying
the machine learning analysis of
biomedical data then you can you want to
expand your knowledge in
in applying that logic using a different
uh using um
an additional platform or additional
environment let's say like in r or using
python so let's go through how
the such an analysis is dealt with in r
so this course is uh
introduction to data science using our
course
where we start from the very basic so
one of the very uh
main challenges in in trying to get
exposed or trying to learn a new
platform or a new environment is to how
to load data and how to get familiarized
with the different uh information and
different uh environment that is present
different aspects of this environment uh
from this uh coding language so for r
which is a freely available language
and there is tremendous amount of
information that is available so we
start from absolute basic how to load
your data so you have your data and you
have a download or let's say you have
downloaded the curated data set that we
present you for your uh analysis on the
bioinfo platform so you want to do the
same analysis uh using our code so we
start with really very very basic like
how to install r on your computer so uh
once you go through this how to install
r on your computer then we go through
the course that is necessary to load the
data that you have in hand into the
environment into our environment so for
this purpose we have the code blocks
here that tells about how this is done
and the comments inside the code blocks
that tells about what this specific line
of code performs and a lot of
information in and around the codes that
explains the syntax and then explain
different parts of the code that um so
that you understand and you get
familiarized with the uh with using r as
a um
r as a platform to load your data so
this is just one example where you uh
load your data excuse me
i'm sorry
so where you load your data uh
using redi.table function it's one of
the function that is present in
r codes and then
it it takes some of the other inputs
like if
to uh to let the coding environment know
whether or not your
data has a header that is the column
names present in the data or whether or
not and how the fields are separated in
your data whether they are tab separated
or they are separated by comma or
separated by any other special character
so we mentioned this and then we go
through
and we go through
different ways or different source of
files that can be loaded into r for
example here you can use open xls
library to load excel file into r and
why do we need to do that we just we
we want to
expand our knowledge into r which is a
very powerful platform especially for
machine learning analysis and for data
science methods where
many uh many of the other
easy to use and gui method like xlr is
really lacking and we do not have xl2
way to deal
data with such a huge
volume and then
as i mentioned we can also find code
that will explain you how to load data
that is comma separated so and and
it's not only about loading data then
after loading data we want to have a
peak or we want to have a
visual feedback of how the data looks
like so we can perform different uh
functional analysis like we can learn
the dimension of the data that tells you
about size of the data in terms of rows
and columns and it we can print first
few lines of the data that is the head
function and also we can use the print
function to print the entire data frame
or data
in your hand
and
on while you are going through these
lessons you will get these snippets of
information that will uh educate you on
the necessary
technical terms and technical uh
terminologies and technical
aspects of art that is absolutely
necessary for the analysis for your
downstream analysis like we are going to
deal with a lot of matrices and we are
going to deal with lot of data frames so
what is the main main differences
between matrix and data frame that is
also given here so uh after you have
gone through these code blocks and and
the syntax explanation of these codes
and different uh
methods to
achieve the same target
we have a section called try it yourself
where we give you a code block this is a
console on itself where it can run
our code and then we give you small um
little exercises where we take the
examples from this above section and
then
and then um
give you in a in an incomplete syntax
syntax uh form so that you really
understand which part of the syntax is
missing and how can i modify this code
and how can i make this work so here
your main idea is to
import and view a text file so you can
use the text file link here and and
substitute where this actually goes this
is where the path of the text file goes
i will just copy it
copy the link countries and then i will
select this portion where i have to
replace in the code block to make this
code work and then i will paste it
so that completes this but uh
i mean to my view to my eyes it looks
complete let me run it and see
and it says there is an error running
code and it actually tells you what the
error is okay so i go through the code
one more time and see that
the syntax is missing the necessary part
of the syntax is missing so that is this
is a table that i want to read so i
complete the syntax and clear the
console and try it one more time
and again it says it says
it is successful in running the code but
the answer is incorrect okay
that gives me more information and why
is that so if i see through this this
particular data that we have printed out
here has the column names uh
written on top of this
and i have not instructed r to uh
consider that my data has a column name
uh
embedded into that so i do that say that
header is true the option for header is
true and let's clear it and run it one
more time
and bingo we got a successful uh code
and we got our code running successfully
and the answer is also correct so this
is just one example where you can
iteratively
expand your knowledge in understanding
how our codes work so this is a very
basic example of reading in a table and
printing out what the table actually
gives so this such an example is given
for all the steps right throughout this
course for for all for even the complex
steps that involves machine learning
and machine learning methods and
analysis so this is extension of the
same code for considering open excel xls
platform and this is for the csv file
and in addition to this we also have
some extra biological dataset where you
can
try the above code using the different
forms of data sets so if i want to try
this one i can copy the link of this
code and put it a substitute in any one
of this or the appropriate
console and then try the output here or
if you have followed how to install r in
your own system then you can copy this
code and then paste it on your own or
console and then try to see how you can
execute this by uh
execute this in your own computer so you
can get a sense of understanding how r
deals with the different variety of data
so this is
yeah so such an a such method or such a
approach is extended to how to read data
from outside of r let's say from uh from
your command mode input or from other
other
from the command line input or from from
a terminal and then we get an
introduction to
what is an r function and what is a user
defined function and how we can employ
that in our code so that you don't have
to write the same set of codes again and
again and again and again so after all
the after you complete all these section
so you get uh to practice your your own
block of code where we give you um
an example set again you can run this
and see the answer is correct so this
this is a simple function that
calculates the number of characters in
the
string that we have given so i just can
verify if it works for
some more
and then it will work so yeah so that is
how
this one works so you go through and
complete the lessons go back
and and you go to the next lesson which
involves or which talks about data
processing and visualization that will
be our next session so when we uh
now i want to show you how
same uh how a similar
lesson
works in the python environment so r and
python we can use employ both of them
for machine learning analysis in this
course
it's about your preference to select
which which one of them but there are
basic differences in how these are uh
and and and in what in which environment
these are uh employed like r can be
installed in your computer and similarly
python is also can be installed in your
computer and you can also
use
an excellent platform
provided by google like called google
call app which you will learn more as
you go through the uh
through the
through the
program so this also deals with how to
install python and
how to use python in different
environment and one of the environment
is google caller that say as i mentioned
and
we go to
what are the different libraries in
python that is necessary for the data
analysis and and a lot of
very valuable
video in video embedded into
these lessons that i would definitely
suggest you to
take a look at and
we need packages such as pandas and
numpy to work with the data that we have
so that we can perform the necessary
machine learning unnecessary all the
mathematical functions on the data that
we have which is going to be structured
data and
you go through a different
function that
that numpy or pandas provide you to
analyze the data to
to take a look into data just like r you
can
ah
you can print out the data just like r
you can calculate the length of the data
size of the data dimensions of the data
so it's it's really complementary and
the choice is yours so similar to r we
have our own practice we have
python's own practice uh loading data or
practice uh code blocks here where
we give you a
we give you an introduction to how to uh
what different
sections of these
code blocks
means that i actually told you and this
is again a similar
coding environment where python codes
are given with the slight
changes in the syntaxes that that will
uh
expand your knowledge in really
understanding what are the important
important portions of the syntax and how
it relates with the um
how it relates with running a code
successfully so this also follows the
same how to import a text file how to
import a csv file how to view the file
or how to print out the file and we give
you a couple of more biological data
sets for you to try and load and try and
peek into the data how it is
how it is represented and what are the
different aspects of these structured
data so
again just like in r we go we deal with
what are the functions and how do we
employ functions in our basic code
structure and what is that
why is it necessary to use function in
in in our code structure
and
one one change from uh from the r and
run to python environment is is
at the end of every lesson we give you a
code challenge so that challenge will
actually
test your
understanding of what is the
understanding of how did you process the
underlying logic of this course so uh so
i i encourage you to go through the go
through those uh coding challenges and
if you uh um
encounter any uh any any difficulties we
are always here to help you out but if
you go through the go through the
lessons and follow the lessons in the
course these coding challenges are going
to be
really helpful for you to expand your
knowledge in applying uh your
understanding to a similar data set or a
different a tweet data set or a
different kind of analysis that's been
spoken to you in the in these lessons
and and yeah
that completes our review of how
our data science is structured in uh in
three
basic uh
in in three
streams of uh um an understanding uh in
this program i hand it over back to elia
for further
careful thank you